yo tout le monde sait gérer chez le
coiffeur avant la prochaine vidéo c'est
promis aujourd'hui on est sur v pour un
jeu d'horreur qui est sorti vpo un
accent magnifique un jeu d'horreur qui
est sorti il ya pas mal de temps mais
qu'a fait vraiment énormément parler de
lui donc je me suis dit ah les belles
tester un parce que bon ça peut ça peut
saluer la manche
ça va tu voulais me caresser je sais ça
parce que je me devais de le tester et
là je vois là faut suivre la lumière
exactement comme là et je me suis déjà
perdu ce qui est absolument ignobles
peut voir une ambiance plutôt brumaire
objectifs fixés allez on y va
what la faf s'est pas facebook
c'est depuis thomas hocquet kyi et ses
deux fils pack maintenant à keaven
fisbach personnes
c'est bizarre attendez c'est ça c'est
notre main très bien que ce mec avis
saba dans un broyeur puis un micro-ondes
puis un four puis toi on se calme
waouh ma mère m'a toujours dit de ne
jamais c'est as tu fait de cacher as tu
veux te cacher je t'attends mais sur
deux des cachettes ospedale bas oi oi oi
oi oi et meg white et me faire chier
c'est la west chèque à ok ça hop ça
c'est de la vie qu'est ce que l'art est
ok un train d'accrocher une tonne la
fédérale qui volent très bien tout va
bien je pense que le mec qui a créé le
jeu était un peu un mec comme ça les
mecs trop dangereux taft oui à ça
à salle unique au large en témoin c'est
paul on a tous les deux des noms de
boulangerie un très bien je prends cette
barque et je m'en vais loin à la balle
loin pour cette blague nul tu as le jus
black pas quoi il bloque pas voilà je
suis tout
ferme ta gueule et vous au delà il ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta et hop c'est mon
meilleur ami j'aime que je vais ça non
arrêtez arrêtez je prends la peine de
bakara ok maintenant ça fait quoi
oh là là vous avez une esquive
je suis choqué on attendait on peut
passer par là on a d'autres vies à léon
tchèque le bras ou la bnf nous observons
en direct il a croqué vu le bruit qui
avait salué hockey doxa wafaq l'abri il
a joué avec des fillette de 7 ans il
sait très c'est les cheveux quoi l'arbre
c'est n'importe quoi
all of the lights salut voila comme ça
alors alors il est où le wat a raconté à
dire un [ __ ] de sweats à capuche qui
vole mon gars il est ignoble jamais en
vrai elle plus qu'un jeu très
intelligente je vais me cacher dans ces
fougères voilà je suis caché jusqu'à je
suis pas cash
vous voyez la lumière au caire sous toit
en plein cul de sac voilà comment mourir
en une leçon dans ce jeu un salut tu es
le plus petit buisson que j'ai vus de
toute la map
tu te sens comment tu complexe c'est
normal faut trouver un truc là j'ai lu
donne trop peu juste avant à 1 2 3
soleil à ta foi que mini perso il fait
du style soul r b
je saute voilà c'était le moment nul de
la vie des habitants times fait des
bruits vous avez qu'à quatre mecs dans
sweet à capuche en fait il ya quatre
nages cachée dans un sac à puces voilà
le secret de ma pour
au multi elle est une manche chacun 1 il
y en a qui mêle à capuche et l'autre qui
porte les trois autres c'est le mec qui
se fait un peu au boycott 1 mais me sous
la baguette aqualung à l'ecal un calicot
la violence faite à la merci à tous
derrière cette vidéo je m'en vais j'ai
cru que ça allait marcher j'ai tellement
fière de ma blague mais c'est pas le cas
vous allez me lâcher a troqué le maroc à
dakar
excusez moi j'aimerais bien voir un truc
juste un truc voit la super d'armes mais
vous savez qui c'est et cet arbre
c'était mon meilleur ami très bien des
craintes je propose que l'on brûle
voilà voilà aussi au scrabble effet ce
qu on a put un petit cochon à achat d'or
j'en appelle à l'esprit du ciel
veux tu m'aider d'accord va bien faire
[ __ ]
sos s'il vous plaît bon très bien ses
bulls vont pas plus de 27 6 mois ok en
fait été du rocher est peu pâli p ok ça
peut marcher
aa je savais à quel un petit coq à
calais pour damon à peine 1 allez allez
bien il est aux îles et où il est où le
feu vidéo où il est ou non t'as pas le
droit non non pas sur la colline on
avait dit dans la vidéo il est content
nicolas était content et si on proposait
tout d'un coup un spectacle de
breakdance tout le monde s'emballe et
c'était très bien en fait je m'excuse
pour inquiéter de la vidéo sont
simplement ces fumées webcam parce que
le cannon n'a plus de batterie et n'en
fait qu'à sa tête un coquin tu es bien
comme cette touche la lentille on dirait
que six ans qui se mange en plus lasse
espèce de bras écouter mondial qui se
mangent entre voilà regarder on tient
pas trop le bruit d'un mec qui mangent
des chocapics le matin là comme ça à
tintin
je sais tu es cacher je sais que tu es
là à j'avais raison aux [ __ ] voit la
suite au [ __ ] de merde attention on
appelle quoi le polo lacoste la canada
goose un tuyau battent conte ce qui
laisse le choix aux attentes bouteille
barbe et arrête toi mais c'est est
insultante et je bous oies et plongeons
et nicolas allait bien aller bien je
viens viens on attendait attendu ne
trouvez pas que ça sent le truc cacher
un peu là eh bien non j'en ai marre de
me faire si stocker il ya un truc à
trouver il faut qu'on trouve une sorte
de croix à tomber ou pire c'est
peut-être par là bas en fait et arrête
de me faire chier
valeo faute qu on va faire une petite à
cotation vaudou je suis sûr que ça va
montrer la voie à toi tu as on veut nous
a baladés badham badal m'bala m'bala des
balais mais non chacun son tour allez on
fait la queue aux petits pieds numéro un
du numéro 2 mais bon tu là ok on va on
va remonter sur non non non ont pu s'il
ya une fois mais dégueulasse quoi aaa
on a trouvé au [ __ ] je veux avait pris
la 3 aux jeunes arrivent au fola passé
bon âge et à leur gauche entre
transpirer il fait transpirer ce [ __ ]
de squelettes la wii ou construit voilà
c'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
qui s'est passé c'est quoi la suite
nicolas est mort
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ouaga faute
[ __ ] ça que j'ai le médaillon faut que
je leur amène là bas on est d'accord il
ya d'autres affaires ok on va retourner
au feu y est wada francky les vénèrent
les vénère ci devient punk fachin le
sweat à capuche apic nous à tuer ne
sortirait pas
attaque